Sau khi hợp nhất và mối vào gia đình phát triển mới, thành phố Hồ Chí Minh đang hướng tới múc tiêu trở thành siêu đô thị quốc tế,
với những đồ phát triển lược về hạt tần sau thông, chúng tâm tại chính quốc tế, lâu sức sách, công nghệ cao và đối thị thông mình là tóc 1 trong thành phố đảng sống nhất thế giới.
Híng Phố Hồ Chí Minh đã giữ phai trò đầu tạo phục hồi kinh tế sau đại dịch, tạo sức làm toa cho cả vùng đúng đồng năm bộ.
Sức bật này không chỉ đến từ quý mộ kinh tế mà con nhờ sự điều hành quyết liệt, cơ trẻ chính xác kịp thời và sự đồng lòng của cộng đồng dân nghiệp người dân.
Đến năm 2018, thành phố Phần đấu đặt thu nhập bình quân đồng người từ mùi bố niệm đến mùi lắm nghiệm của Hát Đe,
phần đấu xí dời hai mình yên căn nhà bán tình dạc, phát triển thêm gần 1 trong chiếm miếch nhìn năm trong căn hộ nhà ở sả hội,
nên tử lệ thu gong và sự lý nước thải đặt tảm mới phần chăm, tử lệ tài chiế giác thái sinh hoạt đặt trên chiến miếch phần chăm.
Đi gần chiến lược phát triển của thành phố làm một chung tâm, bà vùng một đặcu trong đó, bà vùng là vùng trong tâm thành phố sẽ là thu vụ tài chính và công nghệ cao,
phát triển các chung tâm tài chính, dịch vụ, thơ mại công nghệ và đổi mới sáng tạo, vùng bình dân là thu vụ công nghiệp tập Trung công nghệ cao và sản xuất quy mộ lớn,
vùng bà liệu vùng tạo sẽ là thu vụ phụ công tế biển phát triển các biển bốt đế, lâu dịch vả năng lượng.
Với những đột phát triển lược về hạ tâm, chúng tâm tài chính bốt đế, lâu dịch sếc, kinh tế số, phát đồng tị thông minh, thành phố có cơ sở vùng chắc để hiện thử khoảng 1 tiêu trở thành xíu đồ tị có tế của đồng năm á,
sấm tâm trong tâm công tế, tài chính, dịch vụ, đổi mới sáng tạo hàng đầu cho á.